♪♪♪
- Is Micah Parsons underrated?
Micah, are you ready?
- We’re good here.
- Here we go.
- Hut.
- [Everyone:] Ooh!
- Hey, we tested him, man.
- Nice hips, Micah.
♪♪♪
Welcome to Underrated.
The only show dedicated to improving
the video game ratings of professional
athletes. Today, Micah Parsons.
If God built a linebacker, it's
this kid. Penn State. Dallas Cowboys.
The only thing brighter
than his future is this jacket.
My guy Micah Parsons.
The man in real life.
But what about in Madden?
Let's go to our pro gamer,
YoBoy PIZZA.
- Thanks a lot, Adam.
Now, look. We got Micah Parsons, probably
the best defensive prospect
coming out of the entire draft.
This man has
skills all over the field.
He’s a speedster. He has the
acceleration. But one thing I was
taking a look at is his man coverage.
I feel like they did him a
little bit dirty with that rating.
- So I have some of your ratings.
This is your day job. Man coverage,
what do you think that rating is?
- I’m going to go with a 75.
- 59.
[Buzzer]
You want me to hold that for you?
Are you going to spike it or something?
- That’s made me sick to my stomach.
Let's bring in my guy, the official
Madden ratings adjustor, Clint Oldenburg.
♪♪♪
I thought man coverage was low
- Yeah.
- at 59.
- I do too.
- Cuz when he was coming out,
all I heard during the draft
was he could stay with anybody.
- Hey, you're a great athlete
undoubtedly. You’re 17th already among all
middle linebackers in man coverage.
You're right behind Devin White, Dont’a
Hightower, two great NFL players.
So you're, you’re already inside the top 20
now, but I think we can help today.
- OK.
♪♪♪
- How are we going to do man coverage?
- I think we're going to get a little
help from one of our friends.
Kyle Pitts is going to
be controlling a robot for us.
- He's strutting in like Ric Flair.
Styling, profiling, limousine riding.
- He's going to run routes
with this robot, and
you're going to cover the robot.
- OK.
- [Lefkoe:] Micah, your job,
if you choose to accept it, is to stay
with this dummy as long as possible.
On my count. Three, two, one, go.
- [Pitts:] Oh. That’s pass interference.
[Lefkoe laughing]
Come on, kid. Uh-oh. Oh.
- I mean, he was all over it.
- Yup, that's a flag, coach.
- That’s a flag.
I don't know.
That was pretty good
coverage.
Three, two, one, go.
- Go get outta here, kid.
Oh! I won! That’s a completion.
[Lefkoe laughing]
Quarterback gonna throw that.
- He’s trying to run my foot over.
- [Pitts:] Take that man coverage down.
Hey, you lost.
Come on, bring it back for
another rep. Beat you again.
- Three, two, one, go.
[Lefkoe laughing]
- C’mon, Kyle. Is that all you got?
- All right, this is the last one. Three, two, one, go.
- You lost.
- [Lefkoe:] I don't know.
He was kind of there.
- [Pitts:] The ball’s out.
We have to be practical.
- That’s inside leverage, Kyle.
You should know better.
- Clint, what were you able to glean
from this exercise with this guy?
I did see some, some
quick feet, that athleticism
that we talked about.
- What was it at before?
It was at 59.
- So 59.
What, what are we going up to?
- You're going to get a plus two.
You're going to go up to 61.
That puts you in the top 15 among all
the middle linebackers in the NFL.
- Now we need to fix that
one thing: catching.
- We got Micah Parsons, who is
just an all-around athlete.
We all know that.
And his hands, his catching,
showing up at a 57 rating.
Look, we all know you gotta be able
to catch the ball as a linebacker.
If the ball's coming to you,
you don't want to be that guy
that messes up.
And right now with a 57 rating, I
feel like we'll be dropping balls more
than he actually would in real life.
- Do you have hands?
- I do have hands.
- What do you think your catching rating is?
- I'm gonna say, like, a 75.
[Ding]
- You're catching is 57.
[Buzzer]
- Oh, my God.
- I can't tell if you're
laughing because you're happy.
Or if you're just this shocked or—
- That's just atrocious.
- Atrocious.
Egregious.
- Egregious and atrocious.
A linebacker with hands is a
surprisingly great part of a defense.
You know what else is surprisingly great?
The rates at State Farm that fit any budget.
♪♪♪
I want your rating to go so high
that people don't even recognize you.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to bring in a dude with a golden arm.
Jordan Love.
Let's bring him in.
Wow.
- Yes, sir.
- Ooh. See that? That’s the future right there.
OK.
We're going to have you run some
classic linebacker drills, and I
don't want the balls to be easy to
catch. Not because I want him to fail,
but because if he makes the
big catch, what happens,
Clint?
- Rating goes up.
- How much does it go up?
- I think we got a nice range of maybe
six to eight points, which is pretty big.
- Mm!
- Mmm!
- Say it with your chest.
- On the line now.
- Let's go get it!
- Remember, drops hurt.
- That’s OK.
You gotta go big or
go home.
- Born ready.
- OK, let's do this.
- Here we go.
- Set hut. Let’s go.
- Ah!
- OK, easy, fingertips.
Second ball.
- Set hut.
- Micah drops back.
Goes deep, comes in hard to the left.
- [Together:] Ooh.
- He threw it—there was good zip on it.
- Yeah, that almost slipped through his hands there.
- Set hut.
- Come on.
- [Lefkoe:] Ooh, hard done.
- [Together:] Ooh!
- That's a good one. There’s a good one.
- Hey!
- He's staring right at you, Clint.
- I see him.
- He's staring right at Clint.
- Let him know. You see it.
- What do you need more from him?
- Can we, can we get him to flip
his hips and see if he can
make a catch over his shoulder?
- OK.
Going deep?
- Yeah.
- OK.
OK.
Cool.
- All right, let’s do that on this one.
- We can do that. That’s good.
- Set hut.
- [Clint:] Oh, good ball.
- Woo!
- Yeah, deep ball and everything.
What, is he
4-for-4 now?
- He's 4-for-4.
- [Love:] That’s no drops.
- Can we give him a low one?
- OK.
Deep, or you
want him to come down here?
- Either one.
- OK, cool.
I'll bring him down here.
- How we feelin’,
Micah?
- [Parsons:] Born ready.
- [Lefkoe:] Big time. Born ready.
- [Love:] He eatin’ out here.
Good.
- He’s gettin’ real confident.
This is what
I'm a little bit worried about.
He’s dropping.
He's coming in.
- [Clint:] There was some bobble there.
- He threw it low and outside!
- [Clint:] He caught it. He caught it.
- [Love:] We tested him, man. We tested him.
- Impressive performance.
I think the best one was when he had to
reach out for over here on the right side.
- [Lefkoe:] Yeah.
- [Clint:] And he caught it.
- [Lefkoe:] Yes.
- [Clint:] Yeah,
so I think there's some
room to improve this rating.
Micah, how much points do you think
you earned on your catch rating?
- I would say between five to eight,
what I was guaranteed.
- I mean, that was what was offered to him.
Yeah.
- You're gonna get an increase of
eight, to your catching rating.
So you're now gonna be a 65.
That moves you up. This is how close it is at
the middle linebacker position.
You're moving from 101st-ranked
middle linebacker
all the way up into the top 35.
- [Lefkoe:] Woooo!
What we witnessed today was born-ready
Micah Parsons stepping
up and handling his business.
Man coverage went up two.
Catching went up eight.
And so, Clint, I really have one
simple question that I want you
to look right into his face and
answer: Is Micah Parsons underrated?
- Yeah.
Coming into today, we had
Micah Parsons underrated.
You fixed some of those concerns we
talked about from catching in college.
Congratulations.
- Thank you, Clint.
I think that's what life’s all about, baby.